on Prime crime 911 there somebody
collapsed in one of our kitchens do you
know what happened somebody to found him
on the floor an adored Chef is killed in
Cold Blood I just can't imagine who
would want to kill him sparking a search
for the one who committed this callous
murder there was no video there was no
eyewitness didn't look like anything was
really Disturbed it seemed like there
was something really personal going on
here
[Music]
hey everybody I'm Jesse Weber and
welcome to Prime crime where we break
down the most compelling and memorable
True Crime cases our next story starts
with the sudden killing of a culinary
instructor this left investigators
scratching their heads who would want to
kill this man a stranger an enemy a
loved one let's find out
now 911 hi we are at Oregon Culinary
Institute there somebody collapsed in
one of our
kitchens it's early Saturday morning
June 2nd 2018 at the Oregon Culinary
Institute in Portland Students walk in
expecting a day of learning techniques
and recipes yet instead they discover
the body of their instructor 63-year-old
Daniel broy lying on the floor of one of
the school's kitchens
he's one of our chefs and he's an older
man all right is he conscious right now
no he is not conscious is he breathing
no he is not breathing Daniel broy was
at his school where he teaches culinary
arts and on that day he was preparing
for students to come in it was just like
any other day the students had found
Chef broy lying on his back by the sink
the water was still running one of the
students Clarinda Perez actually tried
to perform CPR they assumed that he had
maybe had a medical event do you know
the cause of this or what happened did
he just coll we have no idea somebody
just found him on the floor what made it
harder at the beginning was we have our
initial 911 call that even that's
confusing the callers stating hey we
have an older gentleman down they didn't
even know right away that Dan had been
shot he's bleeding out of his chest is
someone still doing tpr yes so she keep
going the gunshot wounds were not
apparent there was no pool of blood
there wasn't the classic kind of signs
that people imagine and it wasn't until
Clarinda Perez saw blood on her hand
that they realized that oh this isn't
some sort of heart attack you're doing a
good
job I'm so sorry I'm so sorry oh my god
do you see any of the responders no
they're getting him but he's
de officials are called to the scene but
they are't sure what exactly happened or
even what to expect when they arrive
fire and medical arriv they realized
after examining Shep ry's body that he
had what appeared to be a possible
gunshot strike to his chest they found
two spent shell casings lying on the
floor the patient is an instructor at
the location is bleeding out of his
chest the ribs are broken this is a
shooting victim okay we need to figure
out if this just happened and where the
is because this was a large building and
it was a school they didn't know if it
might have been an active shooter
situation and the shooter could still be
in the building I can hear footsteps
upstairs I don't know if that is related
to this building for somebody could
advice they went through and
methodically cleared the entire building
to make sure there was no shooter or
suspect still at the scene it looks like
a lock down I don't know what suspect is
so we need a bunch of people here this
is a building with exits on multiple
streets if the shter still large when
you going after confirming there's no
active threat on the property
authorities have to figure out what
happened here you start immediately
thinking motive who would want to do
this why would somebody want to do this
we treated it like we do any other
homicide we start to separate all the
witnesses and in this situation there
were numerous Witnesses because there
were two different classes going on that
day so there were anywhere from 30 to 40
some students we started looking at the
students first the students that were
there and then more importantly the
students that weren't there uh that
should have been so we tracked all of
them down while you've been here have
you noticed homeless people or
transients hanging around a lot yeah I
found a couple needles in the bushes
right out there by where we smoke you
know it kind of looked like well given
the area of downtown Portland that you
know could have been a robbery gone
wrong a couple months ago somebody had
broke the wind window did they gain
entry into the building or just no they
just broke it and they had it fixed up
the next day those were some of the
things we were thinking could this been
maybe a houseless person that came in
and wanted to rob the place but Chef
broy interrupted it there was a homeless
man on this side of the street with his
back turned towards me he looked in the
recycling bins over there and then kind
of peaked around the corner to the
parking lot and then just walked up the
street this was today mhm it just didn't
seemed that way from him working at the
sink and getting shot in the back there
was no video there was no eyewitness
didn't look like anything was really
Disturbed one person that became of
Interest was a guy named Oscar
Taylor I've prosecuted him before we
know him as somebody who steals he was
out looking for cans that morning which
is pretty normal so we thought okay he
didn't go canning walk in Murder Dan for
no reason whatsoever and then and just
leave that doesn't make any sense you
know he's living from day to day trying
to survive canning I don't expect him to
have a $500 Glock hand gun in his pocket
there's no signs of forced entry on the
building they don't really find anything
as if somebody had done a robbery or
something of that nature is there
anything of value inside the school or
anything anybody would you think would
break into want to take I mean food or
equipment is the only real thing that I
could think of I mean unless there's
money in there but I we wouldn't know
about that one of the things that stood
out right away was that Dan's wallet was
there with money in it he had cash in
his pocket his credit cards debit cards
his ID his cell phone his watch his keys
nothing was taken we thought okay this
maybe is more personal maybe this was
targeted you said there's no students
that really don't get along with Chef
broy everybody loves Chef broy I
couldn't think of anybody in that school
right now know that would be upset with
him at all he's very very kind person
the lack of evidence was pretty telling
when you're looking at the crime scene
and you're looking at the video from
outside the crime scene and you don't
see anybody fleeing there's nobody
running down the sidewalk there's no car
speeding away everyone liked Dan
everyone respected Dan he was passionate
his students respected him and loved him
they adored him nobody had a bad thing
to say about he worked them hard and
that's what they respected most about
him because he brought the best out of
them investigators aren't sure at this
point how to piece together who killed
chef broy and they need to get a better
understanding of his life that's when
they decide to speak with his wife
67-year-old Nancy broy perhaps she could
provide some Clues as to who may have
done this to her husband so Nancy uh I
think some people kind of notified you
that something was going on just what
they heard on the news
KGW said that there was a shooting there
was one
fatality Nancy was from Texas she
decided she was going to go into the
culinary world and that's where she met
Dan in the early '90s Dan was actually
her instructor they got together and
they eventually got married in 99 Nancy
wore a lot of hats she was developing
her writing she was working on some
books she sold insurance she also sold
Medicare coverage Nancy and Dan have
been married for years they were known
to love each other and they were always
with each other sometimes it's the
people closest to the victim that can
provide the best information up next can
Nancy broy help law enforcement find her
husband's killer here's the question I'm
just realizing where is he now he's in
the building oh man we're going to do a
lot of pictures we're going to search
for evidence and talk to all of the
students we're going to be working real
hard on this right
[Music]
now I just can't imagine who would want
to kill him he wasn't that kind of guy
you know I've never even known him to
have a confrontation with
anybody back on June 2nd 2018 culinary
students discover 63-year-old cooking
instructor Dan broy shot to death on the
floor of a kitchen at the Portland
Oregon Culinary Institute investigators
are exploring every Avenue to determine
who would want Chef broy dead hours
after the murder Dan's wife 67-year-old
Nancy broy arrives downtown at the
school the wife of the victim just show
up where's she at she's a 17 and
Jefferson and she has not been notify we
were just kind of standing around and
that's when Nancy broy first got to the
crime scene I just remember that very
vividly she was just standing there
didn't show any emotion she was just
kind of there police initially met with
Nancy to let her know that her husband
was killed it was something that normal
with every homicide that takes place we
took Nancy broy into the van that's set
up for interviews I thought this looks
pretty Prett complicated here there's a
lot of unanswered questions I think
maybe we should record the notification
with her detective Darren posie began
asking her
questions what time did he leave this
morning from your guys's place he left
I'm going to say 7ish maybe 7:05 that's
about the time he normally leaves we
need to learn as much as we can about
Chef bro's activities that morning what
he did was he's last doing if there was
anything going on problems grievances
with other people were you guys up
earlier this morning or anything early
every morning R he has his little list
of things he does you know he walks the
dogs he feeds the chickens she said that
he had come up and taken a shower
upstairs in the master bedroom area
while she was in bed and then he left
and didn't sleep well I woke up when he
came up for a shower he used to shower
downstairs but you'll see stitches on
hand because last week in the shower our
shower door shuttered he's not having a
good week oh that sounded good so after
he got his shower this morning though
yeah he managed to he didn't need a
spotter okay okay so and then you think
he left like around 7 the next thing you
know after that when did you hear
something Maxine called me she said what
do you know about what's going on at oci
and I said I don't know anything what's
going on and and she said what is on the
news and I said Okay and she told me
what she had heard a mutual friend of
hers and Dan's Maxine called Nancy
Maxine kind of filled her
in and you know asked her if she was
going to go down to The Culinary
Institute and nany's reply to me was
fairly odd she said that she wasn't
because something along the lines of
there was going to be too many cops or
there was going to be a lot of cops
around there and then she gets a call
from Dan's mom Karen and then it was
really when Karen insisted that she
needed to go down there that's
apparently when Nancy decided that she
needed
to as investigators push for more
information they look for possible
suspects from Dan's life is he typically
the first person that opens up in the
morning no yeah I do is yeah I do you
know I think Yu gets here in the middle
of the night cuz it seems to me like Yu
is always here and and that's the
cleaning guy correct yes somebody whose
name came up was a a
janitor uh that may or may not have been
there that night before or maybe even
that morning was there any kind of
issues with yadu or any kind of issues
with anybody at the school you know H
Dan is Dan is not hilf well met we had
no communication issues I'm not trying
to make it sound that way but he's not a
chatter we had alarm panel codes and so
we had the history of the alarm panel we
know nobody was there uh the night
before or the morning of before Dan
here's the other thing he doesn't Harbor
grudges when he first went to work at
Western culinary God I'm going to have
to tell you stories here there was
another Chef that really disliked him
Dan said he's just a guy with a
different opinion than mine and he just
never in 25 years of teaching I have
never h him bad mouth a student one time
ever Dan br was a beloved teacher but in
terms of who could have killed him we
know it's 7 something in the morning
could it have been a student that was
upset with him could it have been just
someone with some mental health issues
that just went off that day or could it
have been someone else that he knew that
wanted his teacher position or wanted
his job we just don't know she made it
very clear that nobody would want hurt
Dan he wasn't abusive at home you know
he wasn't secretly doing side deals with
people he went to work tended his
chickens and lived a pretty simple
life there's no you know like he was
like going man that's person's really
got it out for me or none of that kind
of and that wouldn't be how he thought
anyway okay Dan kind of is his own
little world God that makes him sounding
confident he's not he's not no I yeah I
know where to turn in a case where it
seemed no one wanted Dan broy dead yet
coming up authorities learned some case
changing information she said oh no I
was doing research for my book for my
writing that's why I was looking that
information up it had nothing to do with
wanting to kill my
[Music]
husband even if you find who shot him he
not going to bring him back and I want
him back I don't care about who shot him
I just want him back I don't want him
dead 2018 Portland Oregon investigators
are working to determine who shot and
killed culinary instructor Daniel broy
in a teaching kitchen where he worked at
the Oregon Culinary Institute he had
been shot twice through the heart as
police try to learn more information
about Dan from his wife n broy a
self-published romance author they
realize her behavior and answers are a
bit off when they met with
Nancy Nancy very
talkative inserting herself a little bit
but more shocking was when they let her
know that her husband is a person that
was killed I just want to let you know
that we believe it's Dan that's been
killed yeah I kind of got that everybody
gave me the Sad Sack look she's like oh
I figured that by the way that people
were looking at me you're being told
that the love of your life this person
that you just saw this morning this
person that you've been with for over 10
years was just killed and there's no
reaction the unusual thing was she never
asked us is my husband okay is he doing
okay prior to her finally being notified
that he was in fact deceased is there
any anybody that you know of that wanted
to do something to Dan everybody I've
heard from so far is like Dan's a nice
guy he is a nice guy you know and
students seem to like him and everything
why he's not a rer I mean he is he
just it took me 4 and A2 years to
convince him to marry me
yeah she was giggling she was laughing
she was being very talkative she wasn't
in shock but then Nancy finally starts
asking questions which leads to some
interesting details we're just trying to
figure out what you know and that's why
I'm asking some of these kind of
questions can you tell me what happened
as far as you know he was
shot with an AR-15 no I don't know what
he was Sho why do you say AR15 because
school shootings are all AR-15s now was
it an AR-15 that killed him and we just
were like what that it just seemed like
an unusual question I realize and
understand that there's always shock and
different reactions that people have in
a time of such trauma so we didn't pay
too much attention to it does Dan O kind
of guns at all or does he carry a gun at
all for any reason for protection okay
you're going to be so embarrassed I'm
kind of embarrassed after the marchy
Douglas ston shooting in February we
talked about it and I said maybe we
ought to buy a gun and he said said okay
and so there was a gun show and I went
down and bought a gun Nancy disclosed
that back in February they had purchased
a Glock 17 9 mm she said that they got
it home they took it out of the box they
looked at it they thought it was ugly
and heavy kind of scared them a little
bit and so she just put it away never
did anything with it I bought this gun I
got it home we looked at it and neither
one of us wanted it and so it's still on
my closet shelf and it still has that
little plastic band around the the
shooter thing we've never even bought
bullets for it is a pistol or is it a a
lock it's a handgun at first we're
thinking well if she is the murderer
there's no way this is the gun she just
voluntarily turned it over so we tested
it and it was not a match we knew the
gun she got from the gun show was not
the gun that shot danam bruy she liked
to have hands-on experience with props
and things that she used in her books I
work with a bunch of riders I'm a riter
too I write romantic suspense and I work
with all these Riders and everybody has
a gun the thing though that didn't fit
is that she bought approximately $1,500
worth of guns and gun parts during this
time frame leading up to her husband's
murder it was Heavy well course you know
how heavy a gun is sorry it was heavy
and it felt terrible handling it it was
like just wasn't something you guys did
no real frankly I couldn't imagine ever
needing it we did a search of one of her
storage units and we found uh a box and
sure enough they opened up the box and
there were scarves and purses and a
Glock kit it was a ghost gun we thought
oh my gosh this must be it this must be
the murder weapon but as we got looking
closer at the physical gun itself we
realized that she never built it Nancy
had done searches on ghost guns and just
guns in general and it turns out that
Nancy had purchased ghost gun pieces
online however she failed to mention to
law enforcement that she had purchased a
ghost gun piece a slide from eBay we
have experts that can test to determine
which shell casings came out of which
gun the part that leaves the mark on the
shell casing comes from the slide and
Barrel of the gun so in theory you could
take a slide and Barrel off of one gun
and put it on an identical lower unit
and it would work the big question was
well where's the slide and Barrel from
eBay that's the only firearm piece that
law enforcement was never able to locate
with no murder weapon directly
connecting Nancy to the crime
investigators begin to question why
would she kill Dan they discover a key
piece of evidence that could change this
whole
investigation we had a great marriage
but the only people I know who have ever
hated him was his ex-wife and who
ex-wife doesn't hate the husband you
know and I can't believe after 25 years
she'd be motivated I mean short of that
we live a quiet life
everybody around them thought they had a
great relationship they seem to be doing
fine until
2016 2016 is where things we could see
started to derail you know Nancy is
management and she controlled pretty
much all aspects of their life most
importantly their finances they had a
lot of financial issues and financial
troubles from taking out loans on their
pension to their full 1K to paying down
their debt to thinking about selling
their property they weren't paying their
mortgage on time uh there was repeated
times where the mortgage just didn't get
paid but ironically she's buying all
these Glock parts and guns
simultaneously she's prioritizing paying
for life insurance policies and these
are in Dan's name some of
them so it looked very suspicious to us
she would take out $35,000 on on their
401k and she would spend it on you know
getting the yard cleaned up and
vacations and then she of course spent
part of that money on firearms and
Firearm accessories but having financial
problems doesn't mean Nancy's a murderer
or does it I know this is selfish but
what am I going to do without him how am
I going to get wor not selfish no don't
you worry you know I should be worried
about him and all I can think about is
oh my
God yeah take one step at a time okay I
know there not a lot of things you can
do right now as detectives try to sort
out what actually happened to Dan broy
days after the murder they receive a
strange phone call from Nancy this may
give you a laugh this afternoon uh I
don't want to be the stupid question of
the day but I think I need to be the
stupid question of the day Nancy called
and asked the investigate I know this is
weird but can I get a letter and say
that I'm not a suspect that I wasn't
involved and I prosecuted homicides for
over 10 years and this is the first time
I've have ever heard this my insurance
company said just have the detective
write a letter that you're no longer a
suspect my sister when I told her this
as a lawyer laugh so hard she F all the
chair if you listen to that call
detective posie is caught off guard why
why would you need that they don't want
to pay if it turns out that I secretly
SLI down to the school and shot my
husband because I thought hey going into
old age without danam after 25 years
it's really what I'm looking for you
know okay well we we never would do
something like that I really didn't
think so it was just an odd phone call
in general I mean she's laughing she's
very much downplaying it this is such a
stupid little policy I can't believe
they're making me jump through the Hoops
like this this is only
$40,000 the other thing is I said what
happens if in fact this case never gets
resolved and they said well that has to
go up to the supervisors to be evaluated
and I'm thinking great it was something
that gave some additional insight to
this investigator wait hold up insurance
policies and it wasn't just the 40,000
there were also other insurance policies
totaling over $1
million let me ask you my next question
which I know you're going to give me a
vague answer but have you got enough
things that you really think you know or
you think you've got the potential to
solve it at this point we are looking at
a lot of stuff there's a lot of things
to go through and review real frankly I
want you to take as long as it takes
because I want us to find this person
Nancy seems to be a very weird
person just her interaction and how she
had this conversation with this
investigator so it was definitely a red
flag we did a lot of work trying to find
a suspect that was not Nancy broy and to
try to rule out that there was no other
motive person that had a problem with
then there was nothing else suspicious
or anything else that led us a different
direction based on her statements
behavior and activities leading up to
Dan's death detectives narrow in on
Nancy as their likely suspect but
there's something else a bit curious
about romance novelist Nancy broy one of
the investigators Googled Nancy brophy's
writings and learned that she had
written an say several years ago called
how to murder your husband and it talked
about police tactics avoiding detection
by law enforcement if you were to carry
out a murder of your
spouse another odd detail maybe Nancy
did Kill Dan to collect life insurance
money and to live out her retirement
years without him but a lot of this is
purely circumstantial and there's still
not quite enough evidence to charge her
however when we return investigators
find out something big about the murder
Nancy said that she had not left her
house but all of a sudden the
investigator gets a call from another
investigator and said look we pulled
some surveillance and in the
surveillance we see this van pass by
ding ding
[Music]
ding
he's a wonderful guy he really is a
wonderful guy oh man it's summer 2018
and Portland investigators suspect
67-year-old romance novelist Nancy broy
may have shot and killed her own husband
63-year-old Chef Dan broy as he was
preparing his kitchen at the Oregon
Culinary Institute for a Saturday class
a potential Financial motive to kill
suspicious firearm related purchases
strange comments to police and literally
authoring an essay on how to kill your
husband all look bad for Nancy broy
however there's nothing concrete tying
her to the crime until we take a closer
look at the scene as we continue to
investigate we learn that there's no
video surveillance on the premises in
the interior of oci detective Merill and
detective posie came to me and said hey
do you want to walk around and look for
a surveillance video with us which which
is not something we normally do but we
walked across the street to Bellagio's
pizza and we all watched the video
together when the first pass goes by of
this kind of silvery Tanish minivan I
don't even know that we noticed it on
the first pass we didn't really I think
pay it much attention until we saw it
after the time of the homicide as well
what kind of vehicles do you guys drive
you guys each have your own Vehicles he
has a white
and I have a Toyota van what color is
that gray what year is that one
2007 it was detective posie actually
he's like hey isn't that ny's van that
we just saw her drive away in and we
start looking at it and we're slowing it
down we're rewinding it pausing it doing
still images and it looks exactly like
the van we just saw and not only that
right as the van crosses in front of
bagas it stops for a stop sign and as it
stops you can see the driver appears to
look just like Nancy
broy I didn't get out of bed oh you just
kind of woke up and you were alert yeah
and he got dressed and left she said
that she never got out of bed from their
master bedroom upstairs that she was
working on a book our ears perked up
quite a bit just what are the you know
chances of the same exact type of
minivan the same Rim same lights has
this particular scratch in it and then
it it wasn't just a scratch I mean it
was a pretty significant scrape down the
side and so really to connect the van to
Nancy it was that sticker in the window
Dan's mom Karen explained that that
minivan used to belong to Jack and Karen
broy and that they had given that
minivan to Nancy when she needed a
vehicle that was a church parking lot
sticker in the corner of the van we were
able to verify it was in fact the church
parking sticker the van was spotted in
the area without any reason to be in
that area at that time if somebody says
they're not there when their husband's
getting murdered but the video shows
otherwise that's a huge problem Nancy
broy is arrested and later charged with
the second deegree murder of her own
husband when they put handcuffs on her
she said oh you must think I killed my
husband which I thought was not
something you say when being arrested
for your husband's murder four years
after Dan bro's murder prosecutors lay
out the case for the jury in the
criminal trial of Nancy broie on the
surface the Brophy appeared to their
friends and family to be a couple in
love who are entering the next stage in
life Financial struggles really began to
develop in
2016 by late
2017 Financial despair evident and no
end in sight Nancy started
researching and planning the murder Dan
BR the prosecution put forward that yes
they had a lot of financial issues and
financial troubles Nancy made claims on
10 separate life insurance
policies in which she was the
beneficiary of over $1.4 million
eventually all of the evidence and all
of the leads all pointed back to Nancy
broy prosecutors call several witnesses
over the course of the trial to prove
Beyond a reasonable doubt that Nancy
murdered Dan these include
detectives we couldn't figure out any
other motive of what happened that day
because it didn't look like a burglary a
robbery uh there were no grudges against
Dan an accountant I reviewed bank
accounts there were insurance payments
for six different uh life insurance
accounts it was a Wells Fargo home
mortgage I did see a lot of months where
there was loan delinquency
and an investigative analyst that X in
the middle is that that public shooting
range yes the North Fork Wolf Creek
Public range that morning March 26 2018
you're detecting Nancy Roy's phone
starting around the area of her home
heading out Highway
26 into that area yes but it was some of
the first witnesses that really set the
stage so you're in the lounge area at
the the table what's the next thing that
you remember
um the next thing I remember is a uh
student a fellow student yelling call
911 I came to her to see what she needed
I think I had my phone in my hand
already and I dialed 911 I went to Dan
and tried to figure out what was going
on I knelt down beside him
um and I didn't know what to do so uh I
held his hand I
just I wanted to see if he would squeeze
it back and he didn't so um it was
obvious
that um that Dan was gone they knew Dan
too it was personal for them they all
loved and respected him and they tried
to save his life when those people
testify and they're feeling that emotion
all over again and the jury sees that
it's pretty
powerful but unfortunately for
prosecutors they ran into some
difficulty with a key piece of evidence
the 2011 essay authored by Nancy
entitled how to murder your husband we
were trying to introduce it trying to
show the jury that she has the knowledge
of how to do it this could be helpful to
a jury but it's so prejudicial that it's
too much to give that to a jury it would
be too Sensational so the judge I think
airing on the side of caution de deed to
keep it out and once the case turned to
the defense ny's attorneys took their
time their case lasting weeks arguing
Nancy couldn't possibly be Dan's killer
Nancy krampton broy firmly believes in
life insurance and her love and concern
for her husband was demonstrated in the
Life Insurance choices that she made
over the years the other thing that's
important about insurance is legal
ownership Nancy broy made Dan broy the
legal owner of every policy that ensured
his life I kind of thought well what
were they supposed to do they weren't
working with much all they could do is
try to distract away from all of that
evidence and try to humanize Nancy as
much as they could the state suggests
that Nancy bro's life was going to get a
lot better when Dan was gone they're
wrong Nancy was lost after Dan was
killed it was as though the Earth had
fallen away from her feet Nancy broy did
not kill her husband the most difficult
part about the prosecution's case is the
love story that both Nancy and Dan had
they had a wonderful relationship they
worked very well together this was a
relationship one of the only ones that I
know of that I thought if that's what
marriage is like I would want that it
seemed to be an ideal marriage they
personally I think were very very well
suited to each other you know as sort of
Yin and Yang you know and they just seem
to I mean just really enjoy each other
there was no inclination that there were
any troubles in the sense of there was
any infidelity that there were any
arguments that they were bickering or
that they couldn't stand each other they
couldn't find anything that could have
been brewing to lead to Dan being killed
by his
wife then Nancy broy took the stand her
self and her testimony caught everyone's
attention had you ever met a guy
anything like Dan broy before you met
him no no he was
unique he loved me and I loved him back
the person that the jury and all jurors
usually want to hear from is the
defendant themselves she was on the
stand 4 hours what happened on that day
why did you lie about where you were at
why why is it that now you can't
remember where you were at or what you
did that day I'm reconstructing this
based upon what I know in my heart and
what I know in my heart is the reason
why I have no memory is because I was
stunned by the fact Dan was dead and I
wouldn't have been stunned if I'd been
in the building and shot him she
testified fine on direct examination
with her attorneys when she knew what
the questions were going to be she was
very comfortable did they tell you that
they had video of you near the murder
scene yes did you believe that was true
not for one second I thought they're
making this up this isn't true it wasn't
until cross examination that just went
completely off the rails you talked
about the interview with the police and
how you just found out your husband died
and told them the whole story about why
and how you virtually Dan owned half a
block I told him about the full Glock I
answered him the best way I knew knew
how why didn't you just say yes we have
a gun I was trying to be helpful to the
police at this point I thought they were
going to find my husband's killer I
didn't think they were going to say
let's look at the one person who didn't
kill him the longer that she was on that
stand she just became so combative two
different people between the prosecution
and the defense the S Barrel is what is
that issue right yes you have a gun
complete slid and Barrel intact you know
how to remove it in fact you did
mhm you can manipulate the slide and
Barrel separate and apart from the rest
of the gun
mhm but you chose to buy the exact same
piece why in the world when you already
own this exact piece you would need to
buy another one days later what I can
tell you is it was for writing it was
not to uh as she would have it murder my
husband the jury's looking at her wait
you're not coming off as that mild
mannered I wouldn't hurt a fly type
person that the defense is trying to
sell us you think you have relevant
evidence to a murder investigation and
you don't think you should mention it to
the police even though I marked it how
is a gun kit relative evidence I'm
asking you I'm asking you because I
don't think it is cuz it's never been
put together then why would you market
for the police because I figured the
police would come back and want to know
Nancy broy should not have testified ESP
especially since she wasn't going to be
able to provide you an answer as to what
were her whereabouts on the day of the
murder the day of June 2nd not only is
there a memory hole but I have a hard
time making it clear what I actually
remember there were so many things that
she could remember during our
notification with her and then for the
defense to come in and say well she had
retrograde amnesia causing her to not
recall the events that morning it just
didn't sit well with me you have no
memory of driving around downtown on the
morning of June 2nd how can you sit here
today and say that I was driving around
writing if I was down there that's what
I was doing I do know based upon the
timestamps that I was only down there
for 6 minutes or less from the time that
he signed into the building until you
see me again leaving the area how do you
know you didn't go in the building I
know I didn't go in the building because
I didn't kill Dan I know that for a
fact after weeks of testimony and a day
and a half of deliberations jurors
return their decision we the jury do
find our verdicts as follows count one
murder in the second degree guilty I was
a surprise based on her testifying her
performance while she was on the stand
that played a huge role in jury
deliberations and the quickness of their
verdict that just goes to show you that
they did not find her to be
believable following her conviction
Nancy broy was sentenced to life in
prison with the possibility of parole
after 25 years I felt reliefed that we
had put all this work into this case we
worked our buts off I've never written
so many search warrants in my life we
just kept going every direction it led
us and we ruled out all the other things
and we felt very confident Nancy broy
shot and killed Daniel broy I think for
the family and and everybody involved
that it was probably the final piece was
getting that sentence handed down and
frankly I mean 25 years I think we
figured she'd be about
92 when she'd be eligible for release
which there's no guarantee especially
somebody who's defiant and will never
admit that they did anything but it's
the question that the family will love
to know friends will love to know the
public will love to know why would you
kill your husband who didn't cheat on
you didn't hurt you didn't hit you gave
you everything praised you that's a
question that will always remain
unanswered what a case started with a
dead body a potential school shooting
possibly the wor of a stranger or enemy
and it all came full circle to one of
the closest people in Dan bro's life it
seems like one takeaway from this story
never judge a book by its cover that's
all we have for you here on this episode
of prime crime everybody thank you so
much for joining us and as always stay
safe
[Music]